le Conseil Général de la Réunion vous
présente lien social le Conseil général
aux côtés des Réunionnais
il y a plusieurs façons de préparer son
avenir et faire en sorte de pouvoir
subvenir à ses besoins quand on a une
petite retraite
acquérir un bien immobilier est une des
solutions les plus sûres car ne pas
payer de loyer quand on est retraité
rend la vie plus facile c'est aussi un
moyen de transmettre son bien à ses
enfants pour les accompagner dans leur
vie
mais quand on a un salaire modeste
acheter un bien immobilier est très
difficile voire dans certains cas
impossible alors qui peut apporter son
aide pour l'acquisition d'un bien quelle
solution pour constituer un patrimoine
on en parle maintenant dans lien social
c'est dans le quartier de la source que
Marie-Thérèse loue sa maison depuis de
nombreuses années la SIDR propriétaire
de la maison a décidé de la vendre
de façon prioritaire la SIDR propose un
Marie-Thérèse de monter un dossier
d'accession à la propriété
Marie-Thérèse qui n'est pas encore
propriétaire et bien sûr intéressé mais
il y a un problème tu lui sembles
insurmontable
son âge qu'elle trouve un peu avancée
pour se lancer dans un tel projet
elle propose donc l'idée à sa petite
fille mais sa petite fille a des revenus
trop modestes et n'a pas les fonds pour
payer en premier les frais de notaire
l'occasion de devenir propriétaire est
unique et pour Marie-Thérèse et sa
petite fille pas question de passer à
côté c'est Solange la fille de
Marie-Thérèse qui fait le premier pas
elle se renseigne auprès de la SIDR et
c'est là qu'elle apprend que le Conseil
général propose des aides pour
l'accession à la propriété une solution
commence à se dessiner
avec ma fille quand on a participé à
savoir que c'est elle qui achète la
maison donc on n'a pas tu vois la SDR et
c'est là que nous apprend que le Conseil
général
participe financièrement
sur cette aide elle aurait pas pu vu son
revenu ça ça n'aurait pas fait
quand elle a décidé d'acheter la maison
c'est d'abord parce que c'était le
souhait de sa grand-mère
ensuite pour elle c'était aussi
l'occasion que ça reste dans la famille
et pour faire plaisir en mémoire à son
grand-père et bon plus tard de toute
façon de venir habiter là il soit quand
ce sera le moment
Solange a fait la bonne démarche pour
aider sa fille à profiter de
l'opportunité de rachat d'un logement
proposé par la SIDR en prenant
connaissance que le Conseil général
propose des aides pour l'accession à la
propriété elle permet à sa maman de
pouvoir rester dans sa maison tant
qu'elle le voudra avec la satisfaction
de léguer un patrimoine à un membre de
sa famille et grâce à ce bien la fille
de Solange pour avoir l'avenir avec plus
de sérénité mais aussi gardez avec elle
cet endroit chargé de souvenirs car
après tant d'années passées dans un
foyer Marie-Thérèse et sa famille ont
chargé les murs de moments de bonheur de
joie de vie comme beaucoup d'autres
personnes à la Réunion pour Solange voir
sa fille reprendre la maison dans
laquelle elle a passé son enfance est un
grand soulagement et le sentiment de
contribuer à la tranquillité de sa
famille dans la majorité des foyers
réunionnais
hérité d'un bien ce n'est pas une
histoire d'argent mais plutôt une
histoire d'amour le en général nous
voulons aider les Réunionnais
principalement ceux qui habitent dans
les logements sociaux et qui veulent
devenir propriétaire ils ont occupé un
bail pendant 20 ans 30 ans et quand la
SIDR la schlmr là c'est Mac vend ce bien
les familles n'ont pas souvent les
moyens nécessaires pour devenir
propriétaire et le Conseil général les
accompagne jusqu'à 6000 euros pour payer
les frais de notaire toutes les familles
qui veulent devenir propriétaire et qui
achètent près d'un bailleur peuvent
faire la demande à son bailleur lui-même
et puis c'est payé par nous mais c'est
son bailleur qui fera la démarche
administrative pour que le locataire
n'est pas beaucoup de paperasse à
remplir puis je voulais ajouter aussi
l'aide du Conseil Général pour ceux qui
ont un bien en indivision une famille il
y a une succession les gens n'ont pas
d'argent le Conseil général nous payons
pour chaque membre de la famille les
frais notariés
des lac notarié pour que bah une
personne pour lui s'acheter ou régler la
succession et éviter ainsi que des
successions restent fermées ou bloquées
pendant de nombreuses années
comme Marie-Thérèse beaucoup de
Réunionnais souhaite conserver la maison
familiale ou l'appartement dans lequel
ils ont passé une grande partie de leur
vie après avoir été locataire très
longtemps de plus en plus de familles
acceptent à la propriété
malgré des revenus modestes grâce aux
soutien et à l'aide du Conseil général
un acte généreux du département qui
prouve une fois le plus son attachement
aux familles réunionnaises
le Conseil Général de la Réunion vous a
présenté lien social le Conseil général
aux côtés des Réunionnais